hey kids it's me kevin smith and you
know these two it's dr josh roush
and doctors olivia roush um
these two cats bring you me
every week at that kevin smith club i'm
waking big
they brought you me all throughout sun
and lockdown
the jane soundbob reboot roadshow tour
the kids
are finally making their feature film
show them the script liv we have a
script
josh wrote a script how many years ago
like four or five
yep four or five years ago he's been
waiting to make a movie man
wrong reasons and this script right here
and they're gonna make the movie
when right here this september so there
it is where do i play into all this uh i
am a proud producer ladies and gentlemen
uh where are you getting the money kev
in this environment this quarantine how
can you afford this sort of thing you're
saying yourself
that's where you come in ladies and
gentlemen a couple months ago
i did a bunch of cameos on the cameo app
uh shout outs and greetings and birthday
greetings and whatnot
for um uh the cause of uh the
naacp empowerment fund um so
you know we raised 20 grand or
we raised 10 grand then i mashed it and
then quickly
shut it down and there were so many
more people who wanted like videos and
shout outs and stuff like that
so what we're doing is providing you
that opportunity nobody's saying you
need this nobody's saying you got to buy
this
but if you're one of those people it's
like i want a video
where i make kevin smith say whatever i
want him to say
um kind of like cameo but not at cameos
that
they can keep all the money and not
leave any percentage out behind
that's what josh and livy are offering
right now
so i am willing to say
whatever put anything you want in my
mouth words wise ladies and gentlemen
um and i'll say it um there are three
tiers
uh of payment um when i did the the one
on cameo i think there was just one and
it flooded the system and that's why we
had to close it down
so to make it easier josh came up with
the idea of like look there's three
tiers
so if you want your video within a week
like if you're like i got an anniversary
coming up and i need it on tuesday
that will cost how much lift 300 bucks
pretty steep for that kevin smith but
it's personalized i'll say whatever you
want
and remember every penny of it is going
to a good cause this kid's making their
movie
now let's say you're like i don't need
it in a week i can wait a month
then what do they pay 200 bucks you can
wait cool your horses
and wait over the course of a month and
stuff that'll give us time to get to it
uh in a timely fashion but not right
away
like the top tier man but let's say
you're like look i got all the time in
the world i've got two months to waste
uh what happens if they want to wait two
months it drops to 100 bucks
make me say what you want man i can uh
like
like propose to people for you i could
tell people they're fired
uh that's a crimson one please don't
hire me for that but if you do it
i'll do it if you pay me i'll fire
somebody for you i don't care
all in the name of art man we're making
wrong reasons and you're actually gonna
be
part of that when you join this we don't
have a name for it
cavio there we go we have a name for it
go to kevio.com
uh boy that i hope that's available
let's
yes i think here let's yeah you know
what it is nobody's got
cavio here we'll spell it so [ __ ] up
kev k e v e
e e three e's because there's three
tiers of videos
oh dot-com kev
oh and that way cameo won't be mad or
anything
because this ain't anything like that
and we'll give you a special
thanks in the credits of the movie
that's right special thanks get your
name in them
is that right yeah yeah look at that i
didn't even know that was part of it you
can get your name in the [ __ ] credits
what are you waiting for cavillo.com